Russell is with us in Boise Idaho hi
Russell welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hello Dave hi hey so I just want to let
you know that today is probably one of
the happiest and most inspired days of
my life
Saturday I went and sold my big stupid
truck got thirty four thousand for it
and bought a two thousand dollar clunker
to replace it so I'm getting there on on
getting rid of stupid stupid debt and
you know getting into quality used cars
one of these days would be nice wow
that's a big move dude congratulations
that's hard to sell it hard to sell the
truck it was very hard to stomach how'd
I sell it I know I said it's very hard
to do emotionally oh absolutely hard to
do okay so speaking of hard to do
emotionally so my question for you is
that though on the oldest of seven kids
and my talking about changing your
family tree my youngest brother is
somebody who struggles a lot financially
and I've talked to him a lot about your
program I give them a copy of your book
but I can't seem to quite get them on
board so my question is how do you
inspire those around you to embrace this
and to give it a shot to you know to
consider it and and to eventually get on
board with the program well the biggest
problem when it's family is we use the
wrong voice you're dealing with an adult
I assume how old is your youngest
brother he's 22 okay and I'm sorry first
baby on the way yeah so he's a young
adult okay yeah and you even if you're
talking to him about this you're pretty
enthused cuz you just sold your thirty
four thousand our truck so we know
you've drunk the kool-aid right and so
you you sound like to him he hears Big
Brother voice who joined a cult that's
what he heard and instead what you need
to think about is pretend like this was
a 22 year old guy that you are not
ken - that was just a guy you knew a
church that was younger than you like
that you would use a different voice in
a different set of words instead of like
wagging your finger at him going you
little twerp you need to do this stuff
I'm older than you I'm smarter than you
you didn't say that but your voice did
and that's what I heard instead you
would persuade if it was somebody that
you did not have his deeper relationship
with you would have to resort to
persuasion because you don't have the
position in their life does that make
sense right and so you've got to just
talk about not what he's doing wrong or
what he should do and condemning him
because I'm sure he's doing stupid stuff
he's 22 I mean I did and and so
something not all 22 year olds do but
you're you know you're saying he needs
help so what I would do instead is just
talk about the dumb things that you used
to do I used to have done some of the
dumbest stuff and when I got on a budget
and I quit spending everything and it
changed everything in my life it changed
my marriage it changed when I got
savings put aside for an emergency fund
it changed this and when I got rid of
that truck I felt like a pout like I
lost 300 pounds you know I felt like
I've lost a big weight off around my
neck and and talk about your story and
how it's positively impacted you and
he'll probably start asking you
questions then but if you use your big
brother voice you're cooked